can you kind of I don't know figure out
why do you think your starters that
weren't Joker struggled scoring I guess
well I don't think the that's the
biggest question
now let's talk about effort
I mean this is NBA finals and we're
talking about effort that's a huge
concern of mine
you know and you guys probably thought I
was just making up some storyline after
game one when I said we didn't play well
we didn't play well
and tonight you know that the starting
lineup to start the game is 10-2 Miami
start the third quarter they scored 11
points in two minutes and 10 seconds
um and we just got you know we had guys
out there that were just
whether feeling sorry for themselves and
not making shots or thinking they can
just turn it on or off
um this is not the preseason it's not
the regular season it's not around this
is the NBA finals
and that to me is really really
perplexing disappointing and I asked the
team
I asked that play you guys tell me why
we lost
and they knew the answer
Miami came in here and outworked us
and we were by far at least disciplined
game of these 16 or 17 playoff games
whatever it is now so many breakdowns
and they exploited every one of those
breakdowns and scored so
um
if we're going to try to go down there
and regain control this series and get
home court advantage back we're going to
have to outwork Miami which we didn't do
tonight and our discipline is going to
have to be off the charts
um I you said Jamal got a good look at
it did you at all consider calling a
time out there or do you like it when
it's in transition and you can kind of
scramble the defense and maybe catch
them a little bit yeah I think it's
dependent upon the situation you know
and um
their half court defense was giving us a
lot of trouble in that fourth quarter
you know and you take a time out you let
them get set you let them review
whatever play they think they're that
we're going to run and there's a great
chance that we don't get a quality shot
like Jamal gotten which was online and
from my perspective looked like it had a
great chance of going in and we've seen
Jamal make shots like that before so
um some nights yeah I think you know we
can take the time out other nights give
our guys the freedom to get out and run
but with how well they were guarding in
that quarter and how hard it was for us
to generate Great Looks I felt in that
transition we're gonna have the best
chance to get the look that we wanted